endemic
after that a washington journal segment
on the rising costs of health care
[Music]
malcolm gladwell book number six out
this week talking to strangers what is
the
premise of this book your latest book
the premise of this latest book is that
we're not very good at talking to
strangers
i was struck by how many
of the kind of
contemporary
high-profile controversies that we find
ourselves in
come down to the same problem
that two people who didn't know each
other very well
attempt to communicate and fail
um or attempt to understand each other
and fail
bernie madoff
people all kinds of people had
conversations with bernie madoff and
didn't never understood who he was the
jerry sandusky case at penn state the
brock turner sexual assault case at
stanford a few years back
these are
failed
communications uh and the one that
really the book starts and ends with
the signature
case i'm concerned with is the sandra
bland case which is the
one of those
high-profile encounters between
african-americans and
law enforcement that was
excuse me
so much in the news a few years ago
which was a conversation between a young
black man a young black woman and a
police officer who pulls her over and
the conversation goes off the rails
and i wondered
why is it
why is it that we're that we fail in
these these conversations with strangers
and that's where the book comes from
each one of your books has explored an
aspect of human communication what is it
about this topic that you keep coming
back to why is it so important to you
i don't know you know i just think it's
endlessly
no one loves a transcript more than me
um
and i i
am
sort of keenly interested in how people
express themselves and
how they succeed and fail at that and
um
i'm one of those people who
if someone is articulate
i'm
i'm all in
i i find myself so i had a i i one of
the people who interviewed me when i was
on my i did a little
press tour of england
and i was interviewed by the
actor russell brand who has a podcast a
very popular podcast in england
and i've never met him before knew audi
knew him from the movies
and
he starts to talk and i realize he's one
of those astonishingly articulate people
and i was
just kind of
so in awe and my whole time trying to
figure out
why how is it this man is so
has so commanded my attention and his
choice of words was i was i was having
difficulty answering his questions
because
i was so focused on like thinking about
oh my goodness i can't believe how the
you know the brilliant way he phrased
that and then i would be like oh i have
to answer um so there's i don't know i'm
just drawn to that
that whole aspect of of um
of human nature for our conversation
we've actually pulled some clips that
help to illustrate some of the things
you talk about in the book and i want to
start with the sandra bland's story and
uh this is a this is a very available
video if people want to watch the entire
thing but we have just a small clip
let's watch and then we'll come back and
talk a little bit more about it
[Music]
you okay
i'm waiting on you you
this is your job i'm laying on you
you mind putting out your cigarette
please for mine
i'm in my car but i put out my cigarette
well you can step on out now
i don't have to step out of my step out
of the car
step out of the car no you don't have
the right step out of the car don't
touch me get out of the car don't touch
me i'm not under arrest you don't have
the right to you are under arrest i'm
under arrest for what twenty-five seven
counties
i'm gonna drag you out of here so you're
going you're threatening to drag me out
of my own car get out of the car
and then i will light you up get out wow
now
wow get out of the car for a failure to
signal you doing all of this get over
there
that
that interaction ended in tragedy how
three days later she's she's imprisoned
because for resisting arrest
and then three days later she hangs
herself in
her cell um
you know a tragic and unexpected result
but the whole
that
exchange that we saw which by the way
goes on and on and on and on we saw a
small snippet of it um
is
uh that was the kind of when i first saw
that online that was when i realized
what i wanted to write about because if
you break that exchange down moment by
moment you see multiple failures of
understanding of empathy of a million
things so just for example in the
in the in the segment we just saw
she lights a cigarette
and we know we now know that sandra
bland was someone who had struggled with
emotional problems
she
had a failed suicide attempt a few
months earlier
she's upset and she also has several
thousand dollars in outstanding traffic
fines so being
pulled over by police officer is
consequential for her she
this has happened before she's deeply in
debt because of it
and
so she's upset when she gets pulled over
and she
lights a cigarette to calm her nerves
the way that
many smokers will tell you that's why
they smoke right to kind of calm down so
she's trying to stay under control and
in an unconscious way i think
trying to signal to the police officer
i don't want this to go awry i'm trying
to calm down and he won't let her and he
sees her lighting a cigarette as an act
of defiance right it's this sort of fun
and throughout if you watch the
entire videotape you're constantly you
see the two of them are talking entirely
past each other and that he is reading
her
disquiet in distress
as
um
as as evidence of something sinister as
evidence of her being dangerous or
malicious or criminal you know criminal
in some way it's this kind of
um epic misunderstanding and i wanted to
kind of so over the course of the book i
i
i sort of try to break it down and then
by reference to other
stories try and come to an understanding
of how it is a very very very
straightforward
conversation can end in tragedy
so you write of this that you've been
thinking about these concepts for a
while and that you watched this video
countless times and you kept finding
yourself getting angrier and angrier
mine's a process question so uh it's
been six years since you've produced a
book you've got ideas germinating in
your head what was it about this that
crystallized yes this is the topic i
want to explore
well i had been
kind of drawn to
all of those encounters problematic
encounters
between african americans and police
officers you know beginning with
ferguson and
because they all seem to be about to me
to be
extraordinarily multi-layered
on one hand they were deeply personal
they were about
police officers confronting someone and
something going you know
something going wrong someone getting
shot someone
but on the other hand so ferguson's a
really excellent example
you know when the department of justice
report comes out on ferguson
there's two reports one report is about
the actual conduct of the police officer
and
what happened between the officer and
michael brown
and that report explains why the officer
is not being indicted on civil rights
charges
because it's unclear that he did
anything that was in
sort of obvious violation of the law
the other
second department of justice report
which is perhaps more important was one
about the
ferguson police department and pointed
out that the police department had been
essentially a predatory force on the
african-american community of ferguson
they had been essentially using
their power and authority to levy
fines on as many different people as
they could in order to fill the city's
coffers the city was running itself
on tickets
and so cops were encouraged to write
tickets for everything and the list of
when you see the kinds of things the
police force had been engaged in over
the previous couple of years your jaw
drops you're like
this is a town where the
african-american community was
so completely alienated from the police
force because of the way the police
force was behaving and that's the
context for
ferguson so really you have a
if you only look at the encounter you
miss
the real story the real story is what
happened before
years and years and years of the police
force essentially using the black
community like an atm
um in a way that no police force is
supposed to do
uh
and that that so one it's funny the one
of the doj reports was exculpatory and
the other was so
was such a kind of devastating a
critique of what had happened in
ferguson and they sat side by side
right and in order to understand
ferguson you need to read both
that struck me as incredibly interesting
that
because i think we have a tendency
sometimes
when we look at these kinds of
encounters to only do the
first
look the personal look to look at the
interaction between the cop and the i
think we can settle the issue if we can
figure out exactly what happened in that
interaction
but that the ferguson reminds us that no
no you're that just is the beginning of
your job you then have to take a step
back and say well what was
what were the environmental conditions
that surrounded and predated that
encounter and i wanted to do something
like that
with sandra planned
only go even broader and start pulling
in you know
madoff and amanda knox and all the other
cases i talk about as a way of shedding
light on that
encounter you spent three years you
write on this project and if you look at
the extensive notes that you have in the
back lots of documents read never met a
transcript you don't like and uh lots of
travel and lots of interviews
it's
i guess people wonder who follow you
with the really limitless vignettes or
examples case studies that you could
bring to bear on a topic how do you end
up selecting the ones that say yes this
helps me with this point yeah
well
i mean there is no
procedure there's it's an art and
sometimes you're successful at it
sometimes you're not successful at it um
you look for
i like to tell a variety of stories
just to remind people that the what the
stakes are you know if you
if every story i told in this book
was a was a story of an encounter
between a young african-american and a
police officer then people would think
oh i'm
malcolm's just talking about what he
says he writes a book about talking to
strangers he's just talking about
interactions between police officers and
black people
um i don't want that i don't want this
to be
i don't want to give people
reason to pigeonhole this i'm trying to
say something that's actually quite
broad about the way all of us um
uh talk to strangers and i you know it's
funny that
i honestly don't believe i think that
many of us could have made the same
mistakes that that police officer in
that video made that brian cynia made i
don't think he's
unusually
inept or incompetent or
biased or
i think he's a police officer who was
inexperienced and over his head and
jumped to some conclusions he didn't but
you know
we all do that that's the point of the
book that
unless it's just that we're making our
mistakes in far lower stakes
situations we're not police officers
with guns stopping people in the street
right when i screw up in my
understanding of a stranger
what's the consequence
someone doesn't like me or i feel
uncomfortable no one's dead
so that's the i think that's an
important thing to keep in mind that i'm
um this book is really meant to be to
make us all complicit in
um in some of these
tragedies
one of the concepts that you say that we
all do is that we default to truth what
does that mean so this is an idea that
comes from a psychologist named tim
levine who
um whose work i rely on a lot in talking
to strangers and he
was trying to understand um
why it is a puzzle that's that has has
obsessed psychologists for a long time
why are human beings so bad at detecting
deception
we're
this has been studied a million
different ways but basically
my ability to tell whether you're lying
to me is
scarcely better than chance um we're
terrible at it almost all of us with a
few small exceptions and that's puzzling
because you would think we would be good
at it right you would think that would
be something that evolution would have
selected for
and
his explanation is that
evolution does not select for the
ability to detect lies it selects for
the opposite it it selects for people
who are willing to believe
implicitly believe what they're told
because if you do that if you trust
if you default to truth as he says
then
your life is so much easier
you can
start companies you can form groups you
can
you know you can send your kids up to
school not worry you can there's a
million things you can do if you believe
what people tell you you can go into a
store and you can buy
go to a grocery store and buy a hundred
items
and be satisfied that the
bill they give you at the end is
accurate right like which is sort of an
extraordinary thing there are a hundred
opportunities in your shopping cart for
someone to cheat you but how often do
you see
of someone in a grocery store say wait a
minute i don't believe it's 119 right
the only time i've ever seen anyone do
this actually is my
tangent my father who was a
mathematician and we had a gift for
doing sums in his head
would count along with the
checkup person and only if they
undercharged him would he correct them
now this isn't the day before
barclay scanners but i remember being a
little kid and i would just see him
looking in here
and they would say actually i owe you an
extra 75 cents and he would fish it out
and a half
but he wasn't doing it because he
mistrusted that he was
a kind of power trick but um but the
point is that levine's point is that the
reason we're able to do this as human
beings build this
these fabulous working societies is that
we trust right implicitly and
automatically and so if you understand
that you realize that
there's a cost of that
and this is his argument the cost is
that we will be
um
we will occasionally be deceived we're
not good at spotting the scam artist
and that is the
you know that's why madoff exists it's
not because madoff
is some kind of genius it's because if
you
set out to systematically live people
you you'll get away with it at least in
the short term they're not going to
catch you right we're not we're not
thinking is this guy lying to me no
we're thinking oh he's got great returns
here's a million dollars that's the way
we operate
well speaking of bernie madoff
dipping into c-span's video archive we
have a video of
someone who also is in your book henry
markopoulos
let's listen to what he has to say to
the sec after bernie madoff
i gift wrapped and delivered the largest
ponzi scheme in history to them and
somehow they couldn't be bothered to
conduct a thorough and proper
investigation because they were too busy
on matters of higher priority
if a 50 billion dollar ponzi scheme
doesn't make the sec's priority list
then i want to know who sets their
priorities
you call him a holy fool yes so
he is macopus is the guy
he's not the only one but he's almost
the only person who saw the truth in
bernie madoff
ten years before
madoff was finally busted markopoulos
was going to the sec saying this guy's a
running a massive ponzi scheme and
nobody would listen to him
so he is a rare example of someone who
does not default to truth
and i refer to people like him as holy
fools which is a
term a russian term to describe um
the the kind of the the crazy person who
nonetheless has access to
truth that none of us see so the child
who's not constrained by social
convention and pointing out the truth
the the kid who says the emperor has no
clothes is a holy fool right
um
now my coppus is fascinating because the
question arises well do we want to be
like markopoulos mercopolis
could see a fraud that the rest of us
could not see he had insight that the
rest of us did not have do we want to be
like marcopolis would our society be
better if there were more markopolises
and i say no
that you don't want to be like
markopoulos because mercopolis is and he
will tell you this i sat down with him
we talked about it he's someone who is
extraordinarily suspicious and paranoid
he thinks there's a
scandal under every rock
he goes around the world
every day of his life is filled with the
great fear that he's being scammed
he goes to the doctor and he lectures
lectures the doctor on you know all the
ways don't don't do this to me or don't
do this to me i am you know i'm aware of
all your tricks
and he in fact was
so paranoid that after he
um
after uh uh madoff was finally busted
um marcopolis came to believe that
um madoff was going to send hitmen to
kill him
and then he became convinced that the
sec was going to send a squad of
attackers to break into his house and
steal his files
and he stayed up all night with a gun
trained at the front door of his house i
mean
you don't want to live like that right i
mean there is a cost
to having that kind of insight and
that's levine's point is that
that insight the cost of the inside is
too high you don't you know you know you
were much better off
being
gullible
or at least being believed defaulting to
truth being people who implicitly
believe
because liars like madoff are rare and
although we'll get cheated once in a
while it's not the end of the world and
i actually think that's profoundly wise
but should we be better at listening
when someone is saying the sky is
falling
well it depends i mean the unknown
question with markopolos is how many
times does he say there's a fraud and
there isn't one
so he just a few weeks ago actually came
out
with an announcement that he thought
that general electric was engaged in one
of the largest accounting scandals of
all time and it seems
i don't know yet story isn't played out
yet but lots lots of people just
shrugged
and said no i think you've
you're you're um you're off the mark in
this case so i don't know
um
you know certainly we would do well to
we shouldn't ignore them but we have to
understand the difference in the way
that most of us are calibrated
and that this it's a good it's probably
a good thing to be
trustworthy or certainly
one should not take from
the madoff scandal i think the
conclusion that the financial industry
needs to be even more heavily regulated
if you reduce
everyone in a complex industry to a
state of suspicion and paranoia then you
destroy the
thing you're trying to save right
our next example from your book is a
very different kind and it's from
michigan state and penn state and the
jerry sandusky scandal and dr nasser
let's watch the video and we'll come
back and talk about that
it was coming to me with a concern
because
you know and i guess in his words
somebody had
talked to him about
um inappropriate behavior in the shower
and you told him we were it says
yeah
i told him that i you know it didn't
happen
and uh you know there wasn't
in my mind it wasn't
inappropriate behavior
well the court said differently and he's
now serving a long prison sentence
what should we take away from this and
also the michigan state situation yeah
so i have a chapter on
the sandusky case and what interests me
about the sandusky case
is
not sandusky himself
but rather
what the prosecutors did after
they convicted sandusky they went after
the leadership of penn state for a
failure
to
to
act earlier
on
to prevent sandusky's misbehavior
which i think is absurd and i said go
through chapter and verse y the
prosecution was
asking
people in positions of leaders
leadership to do things that they
should not do
that is essentially what the charge does
so the president of penn state was
forced to resign and is still
10 years later almost 10 years later
fighting
a legal battle to stay out of jail
the athletic director and the vice
president of penn state both were
convicted and were sent to jail as a
result of the scandal in my mind they
did absolutely nothing wrong
except that they did what human beings
do which is they defaulted to truth they
were presented with
incredibly vague
uh uh
questions about jerry sandusky and
they chose to interpret them in the way
that was most favorable to sandusky they
defaulted to truth when it came to this
man who was in their employ they said
you know what
i don't really know what that is it
sounds like
you know maybe he's engaging in mildly
inappropriate behavior or his boundary
issues let's just say you can't take
showers at the penn state facility
anymore
that's
that decision landed them all
either in prison or
on the verge of going to prison
um
if you examine the case closely what you
discover is that this is a classic
example of the kind of thing that as
human beings we're inclined to shrug off
like levine's point is that when you
default to truth
you believe in the truthfulness of what
you were told until the doubts rise to
an a level so high that you can no
longer
uh continue by abide by that original
position so there's a high bar
so you see that with madoff lots and
lots and lots of people on
wall street had doubts about madoff but
the deaths just didn't reach the point
where they were willing to to concede
make the
enormous step to say
he's a ponzi schemer
with sandusky there were all these kinds
of whispers and he was seen showering
with young boys but what was seen was
incredibly vague and even the
even the football coach who spotted stan
husky in the shower
went home that night told a medical
doctor who was a friend of his family
about what he had seen and even the
doctor who had who has a legal duty to
report
child abuse
didn't report it why because it was too
vague he was like i
didn't couldn't figure out what he saw
it looked a little weird he was upset by
it but he
and then the kid then the same coach
waits six weeks
and tells joe paterno the coach at penn
state who then tells the leadership the
next day and their response is well if
if this was
so pressing why'd you wait so long to
tell us and
he doesn't actually say he saw
a sexual act being committed he saw
something that just made him feel weird
and they're like well what do we do with
that right
they default to truth
that's what we do as human beings and
the absolute last thing we want to do is
to tell people in positions of running
major institutions that they should
start being paranoid about all of their
employees you cannot run an effective
intellectual community
if you are
deeply suspicious of every
act of
you know inexplicable behavior or mildly
despicable behavior by your employees
you can't do that nor can you by the way
just in the same way that you can't run
a regulatory agency
if every single even mildly
um uh even mild
diver digression from the absolute
straight and narrow triggers a massive
investigation you what you do is you
you act when there is an overwhelming
amount of evidence there was not an
overwhelming amount of evidence in that
case and it's uh it is very easy in
hindsight i think to get on your high
horse and say these people should have
been truth-tellers i should have seen
into the heart of jerry sandusky well
guess what
pedophiles
go go to extraordinary lengths to hide
what's in their heart
you had to be working on this during the
whole time of the metoo
revelations how did that which is not
pedophilia of course but
improper sexual uh
relationships and advances how did that
figure into your thinking about this
that's interesting you know uh
so the problem i mean
a good analogy and a good way of
discussing this is to make reference to
the other case you're talking about the
larry nassar case
which is a much more straightforward
case than jerry sandusky where
you know here was a doctor at michigan
state who was
treating young gymnasts and he was
sexually abusing them
repeatedly over and over again sometimes
in the presence of their parents
and
uh it took 15 years for him to be
brought to justice
not because people in positions in the
case of michigan state unlike penn state
people in positions of authority were
being told quite explicitly that
wrongdoing was happening and they chose
to either disbelieve it or shrug or
look away
there i think some of the leadership
absolutely does belong in jail there was
the condition of there being
overwhelming evidence was met i think in
the case of michigan state what's
fascinating about that though in the
context of me too is
how long it takes
people even parents of children who are
being abused
to take the charge seriously in other
words it takes
years and years and years and years and
years for people who are intimately
connected to
these victims
to
to kind of um
accept the fact that something as
heinous as
a sexual crime has occurred and that to
me
is the same lesson it's a lesson that
runs throughout me too
that
you know this kind of behavior has been
going on for i mean millennia
but in our society it's been going on
for as long as women have been in the
workforce or wouldn't been
it's taken until now for us to take it
seriously you know the
bill cosby or a better example would be
um
uh would be
harvey weinstein it was you know i i
live in new york i know people in the
film industry
you know it's been an open secret for
years and years that he was doing
unconscious his behavior around women
was unconscionable i mean i've i'd heard
people talk about it
you know ten years ago the new york
times
five or six or seven years ago tried to
do a story on it just couldn't get
people to speak on the record i mean
there was nothing
this wasn't something that popped up in
2018 this was an open secret in these
worlds for
a decade or more but it takes an
extraordinary long time for people to
come to grips with
this of the enormity of this crime
and to kind of find a way to do
something about it and that's to me the
the sort of intriguing lesson
last uh i think example from this
because our time evolves uh
really evaporates quickly is actually
another person that's in the news right
now khalid sheikh muhammad
his military court judge has just set
his trial date for january 2021
let's watch a piece of video and help us
understand how he fits into what you're
talking about here
i've dealt with 13 or 14 of the worst
ones right
ksm
zubaida
ramsay benesheba
al-nashery nicole bomber
i've dealt with a lot and none of them
refused to identify
what they had done i mean so it wasn't a
matter we weren't looking for
confessions because confessions won't
stop attacks what stops attacks isn't is
actionable intelligence and the way that
you could get
the actionable intelligence dealt with
is by to get through these enhanced
interrogations get them working with you
so that you can use social influence
after that to get the information that
you want
one of the lead interrogators of ksm yes
yes who i talk to at length as well
and who
uh i found i mean genuinely
interesting and fascinating person who
was asked to do an extraordinarily
difficult job um which was to
interrogate some of the most hardened
terrorists
um in the world and what he was doing is
a very good example of
he had to talk to strangers right i mean
it's a tech
the enhanced interrogation post 911 is a
textbook example of what my book is
about which is the difficulty of of
seeing the truth or truly understanding
what someone what a stranger
um is saying or
telling you um
in his case he
you know he's quite open about it
resorted to some uh
well enhanced or others might say
extreme measures to try and facilitate
the communication
um with the
with this with the stranger with the
terrorist and the question i raise in
the chapter is
what happens when you do that
so
faced with the same problem that all of
these
cases i've talked about are faced with
which is
you have someone who you don't fully
understand and you are tasked with
getting the truth out of them finding
the truth and we see how
brian city the police officer botches it
with sandra bland he totally
misunderstands what she's about
um
and we see that in the other examples so
in this case though the added element is
that there was coercion physical
coercion and emotional coercion was
added into the mix to try and enhance
the
the truth um
discovery process and
in that chapter i the point of it is to
say
that's not what that is cost either the
issue with
using physical coercion to get someone
to talk is that in using coercion you
change their memories so you affect the
information you're getting now
so the crucial question and it's
impossible to answer with certainty but
the crucial question is
so then is the cost of coercion worth
its benefits so i can definitely make
you talk if i waterboard you right right
now you would talk
but
is
in the act of waterboarding do i affect
your ability to remember what you did
right what what there is to talk about
in other words do i harm the
the the conversation
um uh in the process of trying to
facilitate the conversation um so you
have this trade-off and is it a good one
and that's a
question that i don't think
the proponents of well the proponents of
enhanced interrogation answered that
question very differently than the
opponents of it
um
and uh
uh i
my
feeling
in the my conclusion in the book is that
i tend to side with the opponents i tend
to believe that
the costs of
coercion are really high higher than we
realize
and i talk at length to
um a psychiatrist who studied this very
question and he i think i think he's
quite convincing that you're in really
uncharted territory
you don't know what to make of the
information that you retrieve
through physical coercion because it's
so compromised by the
by that act of coercion so just being
able to skim the surface of of your
numerous case studies in here
bring it all full circle so what do you
want
readers to understand about your
thinking and what they should be
thinking about in their just
conversations with strangers i want
people to have when i said end with a
call for
caution and humility
i want people to slow down
to
to understand that the task of getting
to know a stranger is
very very difficult it cannot be done
quickly or easily
that some of the things you do to speed
it up make the problem worse um
and that we need to be devised systems
that
account for that weakness so the last
quote of the book is really is all about
policing and law enforcement strategies
and what does law enforcement look like
if you take
the
task of talking to strangers seriously
and the answer is police behave in a
very different way and they're far more
selective
in
um uh in how they use the sort of the
most proactive tools of law enforcement
um the lesson of sandra blend is not
that the police officer
needs to be a better conversationalist
when he stop people is that he shouldn't
have stopped her
that she only stopped some we should
only stop someone when there is an
overwhelming reason to believe that
some possibly criminal thing might be
taking place and he had not he had
nothing all he had was that he drove up
behind her and she didn't use a turning
signal and that's not and that she was a
black woman without estate plates those
are not those are not sufficient reasons
to set in motion a potentially
dangerous conversation
why did
you exclude from your book the way that
most people interact with strangers in
our society today and that's social
media oh i have no interest in social
media really well i do in a sense i use
it but does the world really need
another book about social media i just
sort of thought you know
of course that's important i suppose but
and then there are lots of books that
talk about it it's really unnecessary
for me to weigh in i think you have to
when you're writing a book i think you
have to ask yourself the question where
can i best contribute to this
conversation and i don't think i
contribute when i just by duplicating
a thousand other books that have been
written about twitter in the last year
and a half this it's been interesting
preparing for this this week as your
books debuted watching the reaction and
many of the conventional media critics
los angeles times is one of those who
loved it wrote at a time when the world
feels intractably polarized a book
examining the varying ways we
misinterpret or fail to communicate with
one another could not feel more
necessary some on the other side i was
interested in the graphic in the new
york times which uh the business section
which i'm i know you saw maybe we could
show it to our audience
it's basically said gladwell's turning
to dark topics and wondering whether or
not uh your readers will
respond
are you turning darker and you're
thinking about the world
no i don't
think i don't think i mean this book is
not
dark in the sense that it is trying to
make the world a better place and trying
to answer the ask the question
what can we do differently to make sure
that people like sandra bland
don't don't have the same fate or
that you know i had to have a long
chapter on the brock turner case at
stanford that's all about how can we
prevent sexual
abuse cases like that in the future
those are
dark topics but the
goal of the examination is positive it's
trying to make
um the world work a little better so
i don't know whether
um but i do think readers
in these days are these are sort of dark
times i think people are perfectly
i'm happy to
um
talk about
spies and
frauds and
uh
and police shootings and things like
that when you started to dive into the
stanford rape case were you surprised at
the statistics on alcohol abuse on
american campuses yes
so i wanted to write about sexual abuse
as a classic example of
campus sexual abuse cases
many of them
don't follow the trajectory of violent
rapes of stranger rapes they're about
people meet at a party
under relative benign circumstances have
a conversation and then something goes
wrong right they start out in a very
different way and so i thought this
would be an excellent thing to include
in my book and i began to go in to
campuses and talk to people who have
studied
this
issue and i discovered to my surprise
that they really only wanted to talk
about alcohol
um
and that to people who are who
who many people not all of them too many
people who study this problem they
really feel that they're dealing with
um
drinking is that this is a the the at
the core of this is the abuse of
of alcohol on campuses and the
consequences of drunkenness and that you
can't talk about sexual abuse without
talking about drunkenness and i they
came to convince me of that and the
stanford rape case is a is a story about
two very very drunk people
who are who meet on the dance floor and
in the case of brock turner his
drunkenness contributes very heavily to
him engaging in criminal behavior and in
case of in the case of his victim her
drunkenness contributes
very greatly to the fact that she was
victimized right so you have
and i think it's impossible to
talk about how do we prevent this in the
future without
asking the question how do we prevent
people from being
so drunk that on the one hand they
greatly
increase their chances of being a
criminal on the other hand they increase
their chances of being a victim
i want to just for the audience put some
statistics from the national institute
of alcohol abuse and
alcoholism
it says that uh drinking by college
students ages 18 to 24 contributes to an
estimated 1500 student deaths every year
in addition there are estimated 696 000
assaults by students who have been
drinking and 97 000 annual cases of
sexual assault on campuses i mean these
numbers are astonishing
and i think many people
um of our generation and
i'm going to um
uh lump myself with although i think i
suspect you're much younger than i am um
the uh
we forget because when we were
on when we were of college age drinking
was quite different it has changed quite
dramatically over the last uh
uh generation um
you know the
the amount of hard alcohol
is way up and of course hard liquor gets
you drunker more seriously and far more
quickly the amount of binge drinking is
way up
and also most importantly the amount of
drinking by women is way up so that's a
whereas in my generation it would be
unheard of for a woman to match a man
drink for drink in a social setting that
is now much closer to the norm and that
has
profound consequences for drunkenness
because
for a variety of physiological reasons
of course women do not process alcohol
as efficiently as men do and they get
much drunker on the same amount um
so we have this is a this is a very
those numbers you
told me are
there's astonishing and there's a kind
of i am struck by the absence of
a meaningful conversation in this
country about
um
how dangerous drinking patterns are and
two i'm struck by the fact that and i
quote this in the book that when you
talk to young people people in college
they don't see this link between
sexual abuse and their drinking they see
them as being disconnected and that is
madness
absolute madness
you've been exploring a number of these
topics as well in your podcast
revisionist history which is now in its
fourth season we just finished four
seasons just fourth season so uh i want
to play a clip from one of your podcasts
which is actually on one of the chapters
of the book and let people get a sense
of how you do that let's listen
tensions rose coming to a head on
february 24 1996.
that afternoon three armano sal rescate
planes took off for the florida straits
as they neared the cuban coastline two
cuban air force mig fighter jets shot
down two of the planes out of the sky
killing all four people aboard
the response to the attack
was immediate the united states security
council passed a resolution denouncing
the cuban government a grave president
clinton held a press conference
ladies and gentlemen i have just been
briefed
by the national security advisor on the
shooting down today
in broad daylight
of two american civilian airplanes by
cuban military aircraft
so what a podcast and this is also going
to be your audio book allows you to do
as as we've been doing today put real
video and audio into the subject matter
how does that enhance the experience for
your
intended audience yeah so we did well
i'll speak first to the
audiobook
so i've been doing this podcast for four
years and i've learned a lot about how
different storytelling is
in the podcast form it's much more
emotionally immediate and
the idea that you can hear
once you can hear someone's voice
in your ears
i feel they can they're summoned in a
much more kind of visceral way than
simply reading about them on the page
and that was
wasn't obvious to me when i started that
that's the way it would be but
you know you can with a podcast you can
move someone to tears
um whereas it's hard easily whereas it's
quite hard to do on the page it's not
impossible but it's much harder to do in
print
but in just by people are i think are so
emotionally connected to
um the things that come come in that
channel
so when it came time to doing
the audiobook for talking to strangers
because the so much of the material in
the book is so emotional
we decided to make the audiobook like a
podcast so what we just listened to was
a clip
of one of the chapters of my audiobook
and
you know you heard that little clip from
bill clinton well
throughout the book you almost you know
if i'm interviewing someone you hear the
person i'm interviewing when will when
i'm describing what happened to sandra
bland you hear
that tape we just saw of sandra bland
and brian insidious when brian encinia
does his deposition the end of the book
we i come back to the case and
i walk
through his deposition that he gives
explaining his behavior that day you
hear it in his voice right i had the
tape of the deposition
all of that means that the experience i
think is just a lot more
powerful
and people who have listened to the
funny people who have listened
to the audio book and read the book as a
small number but there are some
tell me that it's all it almost feels
like two different books
that you're just you're drawn to very
different things and your reactions are
very different do you have um more fun
working on the podcast than you do the
labor of writing a book yeah because the
podcast
you can do really goofy thing i mean i
do goofy things in the podcast that i
wouldn't you couldn't i have a podcast
episode on the difference of
on the on the two hutzbas
you know
israeli let's put american husband and
they have different meanings and
different pronunciations i mean it's a
lark you could i'm never going to write
that in a book i mean the there's a
there's a kind of playfulness that comes
with
the podcast um
format that's not really available in
serious non-fiction looking up the
numbers there are now 750 000 different
podcasts and 30 million episodes that
people can avail themselves of how do
you see this whole podcasting market
shaking out over time
well
uh
the vast majority of those podcasts
don't
earn any income
for the creator and don't really have it
many listeners so the tale we're talking
about a phenomenon that has
a very very long tale much like the book
business does only it's longer because
the cost of producing a podcast is even
smaller than the cost of producing a
book so anytime you have a
industry where the costs of entry are
essentially zero you're going to have a
very very long tail you have tons and
tons and tons and tons of entrance
that doesn't have to shake out because
you know it's like a people do podcasts
for all kinds of reasons and maybe
having listeners and making money is
not central to a lot of those people in
the long
in the long tail um
the issue is about the small number of
podcasts that
command
a decent amount of
viewers
the issue is is that are those numbers
going to grow
will we you know a podcast like joe
rogan's podcast has
i have no idea i'm assuming he gets
let's say five million downloads per
episode
um are we in the next 20 years will
there be
you know
five times as many podcasts with five
million downloads a day or will it or
will someone like joe rogan go from 5
million to 20 million i mean that's the
interesting thing is what happens to the
growth at the
at the
far end of the tale
the sheer number of podcasts i don't
think is it terribly meaningful
your partner and the podcast is jacob
weisberg as someone you've had a long
relationship and in fact in a sidebar to
one of the reviews it was
mentioned that you felt that he was a
game changer for you in your journalism
career can you talk a little bit about
your relationship with him and what each
of you brings to the table
yeah so jacob was when i first moved to
washington dc in
1985 jacob was answered an ad to be
a roommate my house on adams mill road
in mount pleasant and so i met him for
the first time he was a
at that point taking a year off
but he's taking his uh a year off from
school he was
took a break between his junior and
senior years
interning at the new republic and he
introduced me to people at the new
republic
and i began to freelance there so he was
the one who got me my start in
journalism
um
and he we've remained close friends ever
since and
he has been running for many years he
ran the slate group
so slate magazine and then all of the
podcasts associated with slate as part
of the washington post company's digital
arm
and
so he's quite a he's the
he both has
extraordinary editorial sense but he
also unlike me knows how to run a
business so he and i started this
podcast company called pushkin um
and he's the
ceo
and i'm
i'm arm candy um he does all of the kind
of serious heavy lifting and i
um well i produce my podcast for it but
i
i'm you know i'm i'm a name on the mast
head i'm not a
uh but i there is no one in the world
i'm happier to defer to than jacob
westbrook do you also have a cat named
pushkin or did you no i have many things
called pushkin why is that i had a dog
growing up we had a dog called pushkin
and and then subsequently we named all
our dogs after russians spassky tolstoy
um
and uh
then i call then yes and then i um
i used to call my apartment pushkin
and then your apartment had a name
i well
sure i i'm english so in england
and i come i'm the son of a englishman
who named everything in his life his he
named his dogs his garden carts his
rototiller his cars
so it's second nature for me to give
things names
um and then people loved the name
pushkin so much that they petitioned
that it that we would call our new
company pushkin so there's a lot of push
kids going around who was he for people
that don't know pushkin was a
brilliant
uh maybe the most famous literary figure
in
russian history
after tolstoy or even russians are love
him he's sort of a late 19th century
poet writer
intellectual
um
and
he
was part black which is as i am so he's
a kind of wonderful
role model
this is going to be our last uh dip into
our archives
and with a bit of apologies this is the
earliest clip that we have of you in our
video archives i wanted to show you and
folks watching a little bit of this from
1996. oh my goodness i want to show our
viewers your piece in this it's called
black like them a personal history uh
what is this about
uh well my piece was about it's a very
good example actually what i was talking
about my piece is about west indians
and in particular my family which is
half-past indian and it talks about what
uh the success of west indians in
america and ask the question what does
the success of west indians mean
uh tell us about racism
so i wanted to show that not because the
clip was particularly poignant but
times have changed times have changed
but as
a bit to talk about your parents just a
little bit more because in your
acknowledgements you tell us two things
first of all that your mother taught you
how to write
and that you lost your father as this
book was being produced would you talk
about the contributions that each of
them has made to you as a person oh uh
well my
um
my parents
they are on the surface very different
my father was a
mathematician a kind of a
rational
um
physically fearless
uh
go-getter and my mother is
was a family therapist uh and she is a
much more kind of um
uh contemplative
soulful
uh type but in some ways they're very
similar and i um
they are uh
they're they were both very
independent-minded
and they're um
uh
self-sufficient
and uh
um
i had uh
my father particularly my mother as well
had
my father had a great sense of mischief
um and i i haven't i have inherited his
sense of mischief he never took either
himself or the world that seriously and
he
um
he liked he was playful in the way he
thought about ideas and
and i'd like
i think at my best i am playful about
ideas at least i try to be um so that's
from
my thought that's sort of my father's
principle contribution
um and my mother has give you know she's
a writer she's an extraordinarily um
she speaks in perfectly beautiful
perfectly formed sentences that i have
admired since as long as i've understood
speech
so
they have both helped me be who i am do
you find yourself doing as you described
in the beginning listening to how she
says things rather than listening to
what she says well she has great economy
of
my mother speaks
she doesn't say much
so she expresses so i do marvel at it
but it you know there's it's not like
there's with russell brand there was
like an enormous outpouring of words to
to kind of analyze with my mother there
would be like a sentence and a half well
while we're talking about how things
change first of all where do you do most
of your writing do you write in your
aforementioned department most of the
time no i'm a coffee shop
i bet you a so
one thing that has changed over the
course of your writing career is your
celebrity you've got six books five of
them best sellers long time bestsellers
you always do extensive speaking tours
top 10 podcasts
so when you travel people must recognize
you
you've also made a lot of money i guess
with best-selling books over the years
so how of those two things celebrity and
wealth changed your life
well i mean i don't worry about money
anymore i suppose that's but i never
really did so
um
and celebrity i don't really i mean
celebrity is an odd word
brad pitt is a celebrity
um
i'm not a celebrity so if brad pitt
would have walked down the street people
would mob him
i don't get mob when i walked in the
street what happens to me
is somebody will say
hey
i love your podcast i keep walking or
they will say
you know at the most they'll someone
might stop me and say can i take a
picture but it's always
it's not in the kind of
celebrity awe thing it's like i'm
familiar to them it's like i'm a
so i think of celebrity as someone who
is up there
whereas
people who talk to me
are relating to me as a peer it's like
i've heard you i've read all your books
i've heard you on your podcast you're
like it's almost like you're in my life
and
they call me malcolm and they they act
like they've known me forever and they
sort of have so it's a very it's not a
it's an odd thing it doesn't feel like
fame it feels like familiarity
if that makes any sense does it feel
like a good life
yeah i got no complaints so if we look
across the
millions of people that you reach
through these three major areas
podcasting speeches books and the like
what do you want your body of work to do
for society
just encourage people
to
look at things a little differently i
always say i'm
i don't really need i'm not trying to
persuade people of something or
i'm just trying to encourage them to
step out of their
um
mindset for a moment like just consider
the problem from this perspective you
can go back to your old way of thinking
at the end but
just pause for a moment while you read
this chapter
and or listen to this podcast
and imagine what it would be like to
think about this very familiar issue in
a different way
the way someone else does
and that i think
i think is as that is something i try to
do in my own life and i think that
any kind of art
improves the world when it encourages
people
to
adopt different perspectives even if
it's only fleetingly that's that's part
of what i think makes us better human
beings thank you for spending an hour
with us today appreciate your time thank
you so much
[Music]
all q a programs are available on our
website or as a podcast at cspan.org
[Music]